this fearful looking monster was made
out of metal and paper mache designed by
Tobias who's am on it represents a
coal-fired power station Julia Kaiser
helped build it it's part of a protest
movement against brown coal mining and
allows its region 150 kilometers south
of berlin so professionals so much
destruction for a bit of cold that we
perhaps wouldn't even need if we used
our energy more sensibly I think we need
to reduce the amount of energy that's
consumed we shouldn't continue to waste
renewable energy sources the way we do
now I'm social and reverse that fly to
him during the protest the 26 year old
will spend a week sleeping in a tent
here at the climate camp she'll be
talking to other environmentalists from
all over Germany taking part in
workshops discussions and excursions the
participants want to win over the locals
that's not always easy because many of
the work in the coal mining industry and
jobs are hard to come by in as part of
Germany
the noise of the mining machines can be
heard at the campsite several kilometers
away boo digas ibas says coal mining is
an important economic factor he's on the
works committee for the mining company a
subsidiary of the energy giant button
fire
in bloom identity in front a total of
twenty-four thousand jobs and allows its
region depend on coal mining and when
you take into account the others who
work elsewhere then it's a lot more
people in all if Germany wants to stay
in industrial country which I assume it
does then we need reliable and viable
energy supplies the ball tomorrow at
present these are safeguarded by coal in
fact by all fossil fuels young fella 4th
Union everything up the opencast mines
are quickly emptied of coal new sites
are constantly in demand as a result
villages like pushing have to go the
eight hundred inhabitants will have to
move there are some 200 million tons of
coal waiting to be mined under the
village Zebina metal bar is one of those
affected she set up a riding school in
pushing she wouldn't suffer any
financial loss by relocating button fall
would have to pay her compensation but
making a fresh start wouldn't be easy
originally from Berlin she's grown fond
of the village I come from a long way
away and have really settled in here
p'rushim is now my home and now I'm
being forced to leave it we all know
each other in the village it's not easy
back at the climate camp the protestors
have come up with some unusual ideas
Daniel Hefner sells candy floss he's
already seen villages fall victim to the
mining industry
yeah it's super butter so much spin
profits from the candyfloss sales help
pay for the legal costs in the battle
against fatten phone the obvious if we
don't have a lot of money so we have to
sell a lot of candy floss difficult but
we're also selling people something they
can enjoy we stand a good chance of
stopping the bulldozers before they get
to approach him I'm sure of that the
environmental groups and the locals will
do all they can to stop the mining on
this entire boxful now they still have a
few months to win over the locals and
persuade them to put in official
protests and perhaps save their village